ces jours ne sont rien de trop brillants,
mais lorsque les brûlures soudaines de la technologie de la terre,
tout peut éclater et votre
corps peut réagir en quelques secondes, le
virus de la fusée attaque le corps instantanément
en enflammant vos organes internes d'abord
votre trachée se resserre, ce qui limite la
capacité de Batory frais votre cœur  et larges
réduisant le flux sanguin les spasmes musculaires peuvent
vider vos poumons en quelques minutes rapidement
la capacité du foie à métaboliser et à
fonctionner est affaiblie votre cerveau commence
à éprouver de la paranoïa des hallucinations
et un comportement agressif sont des
changements courants dans la peau peuvent se produire des cloques des furoncles
insistent sont souvent ressentis avec le
Flair mais  ne vous inquiétez pas il va bien il s'est
présenté directement à l'un de nos
centres médicaux d'urgence et a reçu
un traitement innovant nous pouvons prendre soin de
vous et de vos proches la poussée soyez à
l'affût si vous voyez les signes signalez-
nous immédiatement